jared with a little uh
glimpse of brilliance oh yeah no he gets
one or two a season one or two season
you know
there was a lot of you know
divide
amongst supernatural fandom about how
the show ended and what happened with
your character and you know there's a
divide yeah i'm sure you're aware of
this yeah what are your thoughts on it
um
i don't think there's a wrong opinion
about it i honestly don't i think that
if the people that have problems with it
are are validated and i think the people
that enjoyed it
are validated i i was in both camps
i spent time in both camps
um
and this is no secret when i uh the very
first time
we had ever heard what was going to
happen at the end of the season
jared and i flew out to la
and we went to the writers room before
the season started
and they
the
they all sat we all sat down and they
essentially pitched us what
they how they wanted to to wrap up the
show
which was the first time in supernatural
history that that had ever happened
uh what was your initial reaction my
initial reaction was i don't like it
you said that right up no i didn't i i i
was uh trying to be respectful i was
trying to be respectful so i i said okay
um
hmm okay i i didn't give them a an
overwhelming right response yeah i was
like okay um
i'm gonna sleep on it right because it's
that's a you know this is a big thing
like i don't wanna mess this up fourteen
years this is yeah yeah yeah
so i slept on it and
about a week went by and i just i i went
to my wife and i was like i'm just
really bumping on this like i'm just
it's just not
and and she she was like is it is it
because
uh dean dies and i'm like maybe maybe
i'm just too close to that character and
i just don't want to see him go
and i i for some reason i always thought
that if if someone was going to go it
would be
sam as
honestly as as kind of the
you know as the um
the martyr martyr i was thinking martyr
yeah and
and and dean would then be left to just
kind of
stumble through the rest of his life
right mourning his brother and his lost
family and and and it would be you know
maybe a sad existence but that's just
how it how it happened or we would both
go like a butch and sundance kind of a
thing right um
but me going and him
him continuing on just i just didn't
it just didn't sit well with me and so
what'd you say so
uh
my wife and all her infinite wisdom said
um you should talk to somebody
outside
of of this that understands the world
and that was eric kripke who created the
world who created the characters right
who had been gone since season five he
left after season five so he'd been gone
for 10 years
but he still knew the show
clearly and kept tabs on it so i called
him and and he had not heard the
you know what what they were planning
and so i i told him and he did very he
did the same thing i did he was like
let me let me sleep on this let me just
kind of get some clarity on it and i'll
i'll uh
i'll phone you tomorrow said great
so
he ended up sending me this very
incredibly well-written email
explaining why he thought this was a
great ending
and it just put things in perspective
for me and then from then on i was on
board
really yeah so you needed an outside
source
i just need somebody gave you that
little insight so get somebody who's
separate from it who still knows it but
but he's not so close yeah but who's who
who is looking at things from a macro
uh
standpoint right and uh
and it did it just it really kind of
helped put things in perspective for me
and i'm sure i could have done that i'm
sure he could have called bob or i'm
sure could have called andrew who was
show running at that time and and
probably had a similar conversation but
i just wanted somebody from an
outsider's perspective i just wanted
kind of a different viewpoint right um
to help me process that so you couldn't
come back i mean the winchesters i mean
you couldn't come back in a supernatural
spin-off or you couldn't come back in a
supernatural movie dude it's
supernatural
it's supernatural of course we could of
course we can
you